see this this is a same ride an elite
Japanese warrior and this is his sword
his samurai sword watch out this is its
super sharp they've been around for over
1,000 years as iconic to Japanese
culture as cherry trees or Mount Fuji
and thanks to of all things a blacksmith
an ancient scroll you can still buy a
totally 100% custom-made katana blade
today seriously awesome so random
question how exactly is this ancient
knowledge of making iconic Japanese
samurai swords still around well it's a
pretty incredible story of ancient
scrolls fiery forges and the most
expensive steel on the planet let's take
a deeper look at how the sword and the
scroll are linked the Shimano Prefecture
in Japan is wild with plunging cliffs
and volcanic islands it's full of sacred
shinto shrines and waterfalls believed
to bring victory to bull fighters and
sumo wrestlers who drink its waters and
sometimes its rivers run red blood red
without with blood
that's disgusting with iron deposits and
that's how the blacksmith made a living
in this region he smelted that iron into
steel until he and his buddy the potter
found an ancient scroll that taught them
how to make drum roll please
samurai swords total job upgrade
nowadays there are only about 200
traditional sword smiths left of Japan
chunji Kobayashi is one of them thanks
to his grandfather the blacksmith so why
is his craft disappearing nevermind the
society in warfare totally changed
making real swords is a long process in
the cost even upwards of 25 grand a hawk
will remove those iron deposits that
iron sand is put into a Tatara or a clay
tub furnace this is the only one left in
Japan it's heated mixed with charcoal to
add carbon and voila steel tamahagane a
steal the most expensive steel in the
world and that curved shape comes from
layering two kinds of steel and
submerging that red-hot fresh from the
forged sword directly into the water
contracting metals bend inward to form
that lethal legendary blade and when
you're holding one you're holding the
millenniums worth of trade secrets no
pressure there shinji shunji Kobayashi
says it takes six months just to make
one sword it takes five years of
training just to polish the katana
properly the whole sword smithing thing
requires patience and attention to
detail
much like the samurai themselves which
is why the katana is known as the sole
of the same rival but that's not the
whole story
for more on the sword and the scroll
watch explore on National Geographic
[Music]